bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le studio
de live du figaro on est en direct on
est avec vous que ce sont dit exactement
viktor orban et marine le pen hier quel
était l'état d'esprit de la patronne du
rassemblement national et candidate à la
présidentielle au lendemain de sa
rencontre donc avec le premier ministre
hongrois à budapest
charles sapin du service politique du
figaro qui était du voyage va nous
donner ces infos et son point de vue
faut-il protéger le lynx faut-il
absolument protéger le lynx ça vous a
peut être échappé mais une consultation
publique a été dans sa lancée pour
savoir quel sort réserver aux plus
grands félins d'europe en france nous
aurons au plateau le point de vue de
gilles moyne qui est directeur du centre
athéna spécialisée dans le procès de la
protection de la faune sauvage on va
commencer d'ailleurs avec lui et puis
nous aurons le plaisir de recevoir le
créateur d'un nouveau site de presse
field médias un homme qui aime prendre
des risques des risques entrepreneuriaux
mais également des risques sur le
terrain il s'appelle emmanuel razavi et
il a écrit d'ailleurs un livre consacré
à ces femmes et ces hommes qui prennent
des risques sur le terrain pour nous
informer grand reporter confession au
coeur des conflits sécher bold et il
nous dira ce qu'il pense de cette
profession de reporter sur la liberté de
la presse la liberté d'expression à
venir justement de ce métier nous aurons
nous lui demanderons son point de vue
[Musique]
bonjour gilles moyne
bonjour vincent roux vous diriger le
centre athénas vous êtes spécialisé dans
la protection des animaux et de la faune
sauvage
alors il y avait une consultation sur la
protection
du lynx k donnait justement cette
consultation
alors pour l'instant nous n'en n'avons
pas encore les résultats puisque elle se
clôt ce soir et elle va être analysée
par les services de l'état
l'état devra être en théorie amené à
réviser le plan en fonction de la teneur
et delà du volume des des observations
consignées dans le sur le site prévue à
cet effet
en ce qui nous concerne nous vous
faisions partie des
associatifs impliqués sur le terrain
depuis de nombreuses années et qui
fondait de grands espoirs sur ce sur la
mise en place de ce pnr et nous avons
été nous avons fortement déchanter
lorsque nous avons eu connaissance du
dossier mis à la consultation
parce qu'en fait si vous voulez ce
dossier ce projet finalement
selon nous ne fait pas une part centrale
à la conservation on a plutôt un
traitement
à la limite clientéliste qui
favorise les milieux cynégétique
les milieux de la chasse voilà si vous
voulez il faut se replacer dans le
contexte habituel vous avez par exemple
le plan de relance national d'action
pour la loutre ou le plan national
d'action pour la tortue d'hermann qui
sont des espèces menacées également et
bien dans ses plans d'actions les
acteurs de terrain historique qui sont à
la fois des connaisseurs de l'espèce et
qui contribuent à sa conservation sur le
terrain sont fortement impliqués dans
les actions développées dans le cadre de
ses plans d'actions or ici
de quoi s'agit-il nous avons l'ensemble
des acteurs historiques qui sont un
petit peu
d'une certaine manière mis de côté des
actions des actions planifiées la
structure associative qui bénéficient du
pilotage d'une action et la fédération
nationale des chasseurs
nul n'ignore la grande proximité qui
règne entre les milieux de la chasse et
le plus haut sommet de l'état néanmoins
on est extrêmement déçu que ça
rejaillissent sur ce plan d'action d'un
autre côté gilles moi alors je sais bien
que c'est pas
la faune que vous protéger mais vous
avez bien vu que le conseil d'état
justement a rendu un avis qui justement
contraignez l'état dans la chasse des
oiseaux donc ça ça vous rassure pas
alors le conseil d'état c'est une chose
c'est une instance
qui a tranché qui allait à l'encontre
des décisions de l'état c'est une bonne
chose néanmoins est-ce qu'on est obligé
d'aller au contentieux à chaque fois
pour alors qu'on serait en droit
d'attendre une concertation et un
consensus large sur des problématiques
de conservation dans l'air que nous
vivons actuellement où tout le monde
semble prendre à peu près prendre en
compte les la problématique biodiversité
est l'épreuve la problématique
climatique il est bien dommage qu'on ne
puisse pas faire la démonstration d'un
consensus large pour mettre en place la
conservation de cette espèce alors
gilles moyne l'animal lynx 1 et est
présent en france depuis 40 ans pourquoi
il en faudrait plus
alors déjà il faudrait qu'il arrive à se
maintenir ce qui est pas encore établies
parce que si vous voulez il avait
disparu dans la fin du 19e siècle à la
suite de persécutions de braconnage il
n'est réapparu pour faire vite il y à 40
ans à la suite des réintroductions
menées en suisse est donc une population
s'est développé dans l'est de la france
en particulier dans le jura où siègent
maintenant 80 % de la population
française depuis dix ans cette
population stagne sous l'effet de
différents facteurs de surmortalité vous
pouvez on peut mettre en avant la
circulation routière parce que l'habitat
du lynx qui est forestier est
extrêmement morcelé et puis me
braconnage qui est qui vient à parts
égales avec la circulation routière et
qui il faut le rappeler est une
destruction illégale de ces de cette
espèce qui est protégé par la
réglementation française et la
convention de berne et puis encore au
delà de ça vient s'ajouter le problème
génétique puisque cette population est
issu d'un faible nombre de fondateurs et
donc on
il a été mis en évidence de façon
partielle pour l'instant mais c'est une
chose sur laquelle on a commencé à
travailler de notre côté donc une
appauvrissement génétique qui à terme
pourrait poser des problèmes de
viabilité à cette population alors
combien en cantons de lynx exactement en
france aujourd'hui et où sont ils
répartis simplement dans le jura ou bien
dans d'autres départements également ils
sont majoritairement dans le massif
jurassien
il y a quatre individus
jusqu'à plus ample informé dans les
vosges et qui proviennent pour trois
d'entre eux des relâché qui ont eu lieu
en allemagne dans le parler d'eux dans
le palatinat le quatrième individu
provenant du massif jurassien et puis
quelques individus dans le nord des
alpes au total on a une population
française qui est estimé à une
fourchette de 120 ha autour de 120
individus
adultes cantonnés
quel est son apport à la faune
en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle une
espèce parapluie qu'à une valeur éco
systémiques c'est à dire que comme cela
a été démontré par pour le loup dans le
yellowstone la présence d'un super
prédateur dans un milieu disons favorise
à adé rejaillissement sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne alimentaire et y compris sur
les strates végétal de la forêt parce
que il n'imite par exemple le
stationnement de gros groupes de nos
gueules et de cervidés en les dispersant
en jouant son rôle de prédateur et il
favorise l'émergence d'autres
populations c'est un chasseur c'est un
chasseur naturel
c'est un chasseur naturel tout à fait
pourquoi est-il braconnait
alors il est brun connaît non pas pour
la recherche de trophées ou pour faire
de jolis manteaux encore que c'est un
goût qui pose qui peut se discuter il
est braconné pour être détruits c'est à
dire que les auteurs de braconnage
dissimulent les cadavres et les seuls
les deux seules affaires qui ont pu être
judiciariser l'ont été sur la foi de
témoignages et en l'absence de cadavre
qui avait disparu nous mêmes en tant
qu'association avons un réseau de
sentinelles sur le terrain ce qui nous a
permis de faire ressortir des affaires
et de deux comment dire de pouvoir
signaler des cadavres à l'office
français de la biodiversité qu'est la
police de la nature et donc ses affaires
malheureusement donné lieu à des
constatations mais n'ont pas abouti à
confondre les auteurs de ces actes alors
sur le chat vous êtes nombreux à réagir
à la fois sur le site du figaro et sur
youtube on voit qu'il ya une communauté
qui aiment le lynx qui est mobilisé sept
internautes sur youtube qu'il ait dit il
faut sauver le lynx en france il est
clairement en voie d'extinction le lynx
est un animal important pour la faune il
faut le sauver comme le loup c'est votre
point de vue également jugé le moine
oui alors évidemment on a perdu
l'habitude de vivre avec ces espèces qui
peuvent créer des déprédations au même
titre qu une fouine dans un grenier il
faut apprendre à vivre avec à vivre avec
ça veut dire qu'ils font à il faut par
exemple accompagner les éleveurs dans
les mesures de protection des troupeaux
de façon à ce que une cohabitation
puisse s'instaurer comète comme elle se
passe d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays
d'europe où il a été démontré que
c'était possible comment
comment tout simplement en protégeant
les troupeaux et avec la mise en place
de deux chiens de protection il c'est
pareil on sait que ça marche c'est des
choses pour lesquelles il y à déjà du
recul de plusieurs années voire
décennies dans certaines dans certains
pays d'europe où dans certaines régions
de france par ailleurs et puis
oui pardon non non je vous en prie est
ce que par exemple il ya justement une
question qui se pose au niveau des
éleveurs qui craignent la tacc de leurs
troupeaux en particulier des troupeaux
de vaches est ce que par exemple des
centres des associations comme la vôtre
peut contribuer justement à adresser des
chiens de protection pour ses troupeaux
alors nous ce n'est pas notre travail
mais des associations existent qu'ils
font ils font ce travail qu'ils le font
très bien qu'ils font de
l'accompagnement et de là est justement
de la mise à disposition de deux chiens
de protection
donc oui c'est tout à fait possible et
dans dans le cadre des plans national
d'action ce dispositif d'accompagnement
des éleveurs existent également
c'est un animal c'est un félin qui
attaque beaucoup les chevreuils est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un risque justement de la
disparition de cette espèce s'il ya trop
de lynx aujourd'hui en france alors on
en est loin tout simplement parce que je
vais vous donner l'exemple d'un
département le jura où le plan de chasse
au chevreuil à de 6000 têtes pour les
pour les chasseurs là le prélèvement est
estimée par la population de lynx sur ce
même département est inférieur à 2000
individus et la mortalité par collisions
routières et au moins équivalente à au
prélèvement du light il n'empêche que la
population chevreuil se maintient voire
augmentent localement et que même les la
fédération des chasseurs demander un
relèvement une augmentation du plan de
chasse donc la preuve est faite que il
n'y a pas d'impact en tout cas négatif
sur les populations d'ongulés une
dernière question j'ai lemoine elle est
posée par claudius qu'on salue lorsqu un
être humain ou un pire un enfant sera
atik clip sera attaqué par un animal
sauvage réintroduit dans notre
territoire qui sera responsable
alors on peut toujours penser au pire
moi je vais vous parler de ce qui s'est
passé dans l'est dans les périodes
historiques dans les décennies passées 0
attaques liées aux lynx c'est un animal
qui a peur de l'homme et qui a de bonnes
raisons d'avoir peur de l'homme
puisqu'il n'a payé de sa disparition
les seule interaction violente qu'il ya
pu y avoir entre le lynx est d'aider des
humains c'est lors de parties de chasse
lorsque des chiens ont cerné un lynx et
que le lynx en se défendant a blessé des
chiens il n'y a aucune attaque référence
et documenté sur l'espèce humaine qu'il
s'agisse d'enfants ou d'adultes
dernière qui est sûr d'être une
objection justement du même internaute
qui lie si nos anciens ont détruit les
ours et les loups alors il parle pas des
lynx il y avait peut-être une raison
oui alors dans cl nos anciens pratiqué
l'esclavagé avait peut-être une raison
aussi maintenant il n'empêche qu'on a
aboli un certain nombre pratique
fâcheuse et la destruction des grands
prédateurs il ya peut-être deux choses
c'est pas là le même ordre quand même
c'est pas le lord le même ordre de la
même nature de problèmes quand même
entre l'esclavagé c'est l'extinction de
l'espèce du loup
oui enfin il faut mettre en balance ce
qui peut être mis en balance
effectivement on va juste rappeler que
actuellement 96 % de la biomasse
vertébrés est constituée par l'espèce
humaine et ses espèces données et ses
animaux domestiques 4% ce sont les
animaux sauvages laissons-leur une place
c'est aussi notre survie qui est en
question si vous voulez la biodiversité
qui est un grand mot on peut comparer ça
à notre microbiote microbiote de
l'humanité on a besoin de ça pour
survivre je ne suis pas seul à le dire
mais si on enlève une espèce si on en
aurait une autre c'est comme si on
enlève les briques d'un mur un jour un
mur s'effondre et c'est la survie de
l'humanité qui est en cause merci
beaucoup gilles moyne pour avoir répondu
à une question qui était franche et vos
réponses qu'ils ont été très clairs
merci beaucoup si l'on parlait si je
peux me permettre il reste quelques
minutes pour participer à la
consultation pour les personnes qui
veulent faire valoir leurs avis pour ou
contre en tout cas je souhaite qu'elle
fasse une critique objective de ce plan
national d'action et on peut aller
justement sur le site notamment du
centre athénas merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions gilles
moyne et nous avoir fait en plus voyager
un peu dans ces magnifiques régions du
massif jurassien et de l'est de la
france et on a salue d'ailleurs tous les
internautes de ces régions dans
l'actualité aussi les coulisses de la
visite de marine le pen à budapest
charles sapin était du voyage voici en
attendant ces infos les principales
images de ce déplacement
[Musique]
e
l'union européenne n'est plus nous
savons une organisation internationale
inter
national entre les nations elle a dérivé
en organisation fédérale puis en
véritable pouvoir centralisé bruch ses
lois enivré de sa propre existence de sa
puissance de son omnipotence comme je
suis fondamentalement
attachés à la souveraineté de chacune
des nations il ne me viendrait pas à
l'esprit de venir comme le font trop
souvent d'ailleurs certains journalistes
donner des leçons aux peuples quels
qu'ils soient et en l'occurrence au
peuple hongrois
bonjour je trouve sapin bonjour que se
sont dit exactement marine le pen viktor
orban alors ben comme là vous voyez vous
venez de voir un extrait c'était un
certain sens ils sont dix pas des choses
capitales l'intérêt était déjà dans
cette rencontre il faut savoir que
marine le pen et viktor orban ne
s'étaient jamais rencontrés de visu ne
s'était jamais vu jusqu'à présent ils
avaient eux-mêmes refusé de la recevoir
exactement à en 2016 exactement on m'a
en fait avant 2018 viktor orban était
membre d'un groupe important d'ailleurs
le principal groupe au parlement
européen qui s'appelle le populeux ppe
qui est un membre à un groupe dans
lequel les membres notamment le parti de
l'est républicain est déjà passée
décision politique au niveau national
que ça soit sur la presse sur les lgbt
sur le refus de certaines directives
européennes faisait déjà grincer des
dents au sein de ce parti il ne voulait
pas en rajouter en s'affichant avec une
leader nationaliste tels que marine le
pen qui pourrait en fait provoquer son
renvoi de ce groupe bon il se trouve que
pression et dans et il
il n'a pas eu d'autre solution en 2018
que de quitter ce groupe est maintenant
mieux que mieux que libre libéré de ce
groupe il n'avait plus les mêmes
obstacles a rencontré marine le pen avec
qui ils partagent quelques quelques
points de vue idéologique notamment
contre contre l'immigration sur
l'importance l'importance des frontières
nationales mais qu'ils ont aussi des
divergences 1 notamment sur tout ce qui
est sociétale viktor orban est un
conservateur alors que marine le pen ne
l'est ne l'est pas plus que ça et
généralement on disait que marine le pen
était plus à droite que viktor orban ah
bon c'était ce qu'on disait puisqu'il ya
également le parti jobbik en hongrie qui
est un parti qui est plus à droite que
lui marine le pen a refusé le jobic dans
le groupe au parlement européen donc
voilà et en fait si on veut vraiment
prendre une classification gauche droite
viktor orban est à la fois plus libérale
est plus conservateur que marine le pen
qui sont deux thèmes finalement
constitutifs de la droite on pourrait
dire que marine le pen est plus à gauche
que viktor orban mais voilà c'est après
les deux sont des dirigeants
nationalistes et il se retrouve sur ce
qui pour eux est l'essentiel c'est à
dire le retour au souveraineté de leur
pays la défense contre les mouvements de
population illégaux les migrations et la
défense d'une identité forte de leur
payer ils s'opposent et d'ailleurs ils
l'ont redit hier lors de cette
conférence de presse commune il s'oppose
à la mutation de l'union européenne en 1
en un état supra supranationale un état
un institut super état qui viendraient
imposer ses vues aux états membres voilà
il pense qu'elle a une chance
je pense qu'il ne se place pas sur ce
sursaut sur cette position là il est
viktor orban est un pragmatique
la la venue de marine le pen avait des
avantages non pas pour l'éventuelle
victoire de marine le pen à la prochaine
présidentielle mais déjà c'est un
avantage pour lui il faut savoir qu'il a
des élections très importantes en avril
2022 c'est à peu près le même calendrier
et il a besoin pour ressouder ses
troupes et pour parler à son électorat
de faire venir des figures un peu
radicale et notamment des figures qui
deviennent d'autre part que de son pays
parce que ça a été beaucoup dit dans son
pays qu'à partir du moment où il a
quitté le ppe qui était principal
les gens disaient viktor orban est
isolée donc il est important pour lui de
s'afficher avec des leaders européens et
marine le pen est connu en grimm j'ai pu
voir lors de son déplacement s'est fait
arrêter noir à la notoriété qui dépasse
quand même très largement les frontières
nationales qui a sollicité cette
rencontre c'est marine le pen c'est
marine le pen en fait c'est une
rencontre qui qui est dans les tuyaux
depuis très très longtemps
très très longtemps depuis 2018
puisque viktor orban a quitté ce groupe
ppe en fait il eu des contacts qui ont
été repris mais c'était finalement
c'était un peu bloquée si vous voulez
c'était un peu il avait pas vraiment de
date c'est au coeur de l'été
quand a été rendu public la venue d'eric
zemmour et de marion maréchal dans le
cadre d'une conférence d'intellectuels
sur la défense de la famille là ça un
peu agité le cabinet de marine le pen en
disant attendez c'est pas possible nous
a fait des années qu'on demande avoir
viktor orban il faut s'activer donc elle
a demandé à ses troupes à certains de
ses assistants parlementaires de
s'activer auprès de victor aubaine c'est
là où a été décidée cette visite de deux
jours qui a eu lieu donc hier et
avant-hier hong lei on a vu quand même
que urban en tout cas le l'entourage de
marine le pen dans l'article en tous les
cas telle que vous la raconte et se
vante d'avoir qu'ils aient eu un accueil
en plus grande pompe que que pour eric
zemmour mais c'est vrai abba totalement
mai d'ailleurs c'est assez bien juge de
viktor orban en fait les hongrois ont
quelque chose comme beaucoup de pas de
petits pays je veux pas être enfin je
veux pas les vexer mais deux pays un peu
plus modeste que de grandes puissances
comme la france on joue de la diplomatie
de façon très habile victoire au bagne
fine stratégie qu'on appelle là c'est un
peu la diplomatie du gyrophare c'est à
dire qu'une personne qu'il a envie de
traiter ce qu'il a fait avec marine le
pen c'est alors dès la descente d'avion
c'est policiers en uniforme cortège de
dix voitures officielles alors que la
délégation marine le pen c'était six
personnes donc où il ya des voitures
conduites circulent à vide dix voitures
noires sombre vitres teintées gyrophare
avec tout un parcours qui est alors on
s'arrête à la basilique sainte etienne
quand elles valent elles rentrent dans
la physique saint-etienne il y à l'orgue
qui se met à jouer du bach elle va dans
un restaurant cdc des musiciens qui se
met à jouer du edith piaf on sort le
tapis rouge elle a été reçue si vous
voulez pas comme une chef de parti a été
reçu comme un chef de gouvernement comme
un chef d'état et il y a quelque chose
de 2,2 revigorant pour ses troupes et
pour elle même
puisque depuis le début de l'année
depuis le début depuis cette rentrée
elle a été quand même particulièrement
par tueur perturbé par cette percée
d'eric zemmour elle a raté beaucoup de
séquences elle est en baisse dans les
sondages y avait un manque de dynamique
est là finalement de se voir traitée
comme une chef d'état ça a revigoré les
troupes et même elle elle en a tiré un
bénéfice l'impression qu'elle était au
fric
euphorique non ce n'est pas le c'est pas
le mot je sais à l'été
a été galvanisé elle était galvanisé et
à l'appel en fait c'est une pour tous
pour enfin vraiment objectivement d'un
point de vue journalistique si on
reprend toutes les séquences qui se sont
succédé depuis le début septembre c'est
la première séquence réussie de la
rentrée
2 de marine le pen je vous propose
d'écouter l'analyse d'emmanuel rivière
qui était votre place lundi soir
justement sur la perte de dynamique de
marine le pen et on y revient juste prêt
est l'un des enseignements pour fermer
la parenthèse c'est que marine le pen
qui pendant beaucoup de scrutin tout
soit elle ou le rassemblement national
paraissait très solide sur un socle très
fidèle montre là une faiblesse que l'on
pressentait est effectivement
l'instrument la révélation de cette
faiblesse c'est eric zemmour qui montre
qu'il peut donner envie à bonne partie
de son électorat d'aller voir ailleurs
cette faille cette faiblesse charles est
ce qu elle en est consciente
alors cette faille elle en est
consciente parce qu'elle l'a vu de façon
si non séparées au delà du phénomène
eric zemmour a été confronté à cette
réalité lors du dernier scrutin les
élections régionales
tous les sondages étaient unanimes elle
devait gagner au minimum une région
notamment la provence alpes côte d'azur
voilà vous en avait d'ailleurs parlé à
ce moment là sur ce plateau
finalement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au
soir du premier tour
impossible à gagner le plafond de verre
les électeurs de marine le pen ne se
sont pas déplacés
les stratèges du rassemblement national
et marine le pen également se sont
rendus compte qu'il y avait eu une
erreur d'analysé qui ne capitalisait
plus sur les colères mais au contraire
il les avait transformés en fatalisme
c'est à dire que des gens qui depuis
2015 de 2015 à 2017 ont voté
rassemblement national front national à
l'époque parce qu'ils en avaient marre
parce qu'il voulait faire un cri de
colère voir parce qu'il voulait
retourner la table et maîtres marine le
pen au pouvoir ces gens là sont passés
d'un vote de rupture qu'est le vote et
rennes à une rupture totale avec les
urnes c'est à dire que finalement le
vote rmc retrouver la dernière marche
avant l'abstention est que les électeurs
de marine le pen finalement se vider par
le par le bas
allez rejoindre les corps de plus en
plus importante de l'abstention et donc
il y avait un véritable sujet de
mobilisation de ses électeurs plutôt que
lorqu'elle était déjà dans une stratégie
en conquérir d'autres vous souvenez l
alizé l'électorat et l'air l'électorat
bourgeois sauf qu'avant même de réussir
cette stratégie a le voit que les
classes populaires le choeur les
vraiment le coeur de l'électorat le
socle granitique jusqu'à présent de de
marine le pen en fait commencé à se
liquéfier dans l'abstention elle pense
toujours que que zemmour va s'effondrer
comme bellamy en 2019 oui oui elle le
pense si vous voulez alors ce qui est
très intéressant mais moi c'est pour ça
que un peu cyniquement en tant qu
observateur politique moi je trouve
cette période passionnante c'est qu'on
vit quelque chose qui est inédit on a
connu un phénomène de primaires à droite
pour ce notamment en 2016 on l'a vu à
gauche paris en 2016 mais sur ce morceau
là de l'échiquier politique sur sur dans
le camp nationaliste ça n'est jamais
réellement arrivé il ya eu des
adversités picrocholines maigret mais
qui a jamais compté philippe de villiers
pareil il n'était jamais très haut
nicolas dupont aignan il est 5 mais je
veux dire c'est il a jamais mis en
danger une candidature front national
puis rmp souffle aux élections
européennes
en matière de villiers ah oui oui non
mais passe pas ce niveau là et si vous
voulez là on est en train de voir une
véritable opposition comme on en voit
dans les dents des primaires où on a
deux offres qui ne se limite pas à une
différence d'incarnation mais une
véritable différence idéologique il se
retrouve sur l'immigration il se
retrouve sur l'identité mais y en a un
qui est libérale qui veut une retraite à
64 ans et règlements l'autre marine le
pen qui veut une retraite à 60 ans et
qui met en avant sa fibre sociale il y
en a un qui est conservateur qui
regrette le mariage pour tous qui veut
mettre un terme à l'élargissement de la
pma qui compte la gpa une marine le pen
qui n'est pas conservatrice qui pour
elle ces sujets sociétaux n'ont pas
d'importance se passe après et même dans
l'eure dans leur façon d'appréhender la
conquête du pouvoir c'est différent
c'est très drôle eric zemmour
lui il veut une conquête en faisant
l'union des droites c'est à dire en
parlant à la fois aux classes populaires
mais aussi à une partie de la
bourgeoisie qu'il dit patriote alors que
marine le pen allait aller dans ce sens
cosy 2006 exactement ce que ce qui a été
brisé patrick buisson et enfin même de
gaulle avant lui et de l'autre et marine
le pen qui elle pour eux et pour un
souverainisme intégral si vous voulez
réconcilier les souverainistes des deux
bords de gauche et de droite arnaud
montebourg et l ensemble des classes
populaires
quelle est l'ambiance dans dans
l'entourage actuellement or cette
galvanisation suite canalisations
ponctuelles ensuite cette visite à
abidal est
l'ambiance n'est pas bonne l'ambiance
est allé l'incompréhension quand on
discute avec des stratèges de marine le
pen et ses voies la sas c'est vraiment
de l'incompréhension c'est à dire on
comprend pas on a tout bien fait
on sait que marine le pen repoussé
énormément au second tour du coup on a
recentré notre discours on a lissé
certaines choses pour susciter moins de
rejet
que emmanuel macron n'at on a montré
pendant ces quatre dernières années que
on voit là on a toujours joué la carte
de la responsabilité lors des gilets
jaunes lors des retraites lors même de
la crise sanitaire marine le pen n'a pas
couru avec une allumette
voilà dans la station essence pour
mettre le feu à la au contraire essayer
d'apaiser les choses et si vous voulez
ils se disent tout a plutôt pas mal
marché ils ont absolument pas vu venir
eric zemmour et ils n'ont toujours pas
compris d'où il venait donc c'est vrai
là dessus il ya un peu une
incompréhension c'est à dire que
si eric zemmour avec son discours un peu
radical est l'incarnation de tout ce
qu'ils ont voulu combattre depuis dix
ans c'est l'anti dédiabolisation or pour
leur stratégie de dédiabolisation et est
un succès est arrivé à son terme devait
amener marine le pen au pouvoir et là il
ya quelqu'un qui arrive qui est la
négation de tout ce qu'ils ont fait
depuis dix ans et qui leur coupe la
chique soudain cessé quand même voilà
donc ils sont un peu
exactement quel est le prochain voyage
de marine le pen elle compte revoir
poutine alors ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas d'actualité tout il pour
différentes raisons notamment pour les
raisons pour lesquelles elle était elle
était en hongrie il essaye en fait de
constituer un groupe très compliqué il
ya très peu de chances que ça arrive à
terme avant la présidentielle il essaye
de constituer un groupe gênant au
parlement européen de souverainistes qui
permettrait d'être si ce n'est le
premier groupe en tout cas le deuxième
ou le troisième pour pouvoir voilà plus
jouer au sein de l'union européenne et
si vous voulez pour constituer ce groupe
il faut notamment avoir comme allié les
polonais polonais qui sont très anti
poutine donc ça serait ça serait
vraiment malvenu de voir poutine ans
maintenant les prochains rendez vous
internationaux de marine le pen sont
gardés secrets mais je peux je ne les
connais pas mais je sais qu'il y en a en
préparation ils sont gardés jalousement
par l'équipe de campagne et les
il va falloir lui poser la question
c'est pas je pense que le rencontrer à
moins d'un moins d'intérêt que
il ya cinq ans quand il était au pouvoir
au kosovo en tout cas pour lui poser des
questions merci beaucoup charles sapin
votre goût du voyage de marine le pen à
budapest et à retrouver dans le figaro
et justement toute la difficulté juste
de 7,2 ce souverainisme qui est parfois
un obstacle la constitution d'un groupe
international vous l'expliqué très bien
dans cet article on signale également
votre dernier livre avec françois-xavier
bourmaud macron le pen le tombeau des
fossoyeurs aux éditions de l'archipel
non seulement le signal mais on le
recommande surtout et on va peut parler
maintenant de notre métier avec un
journaliste qui n'a pas froid aux yeux
et qui essaye de comprendre de faire
connaître et de faire comprendre le
monde il s'appelle emmanuel razavi et il
ne nous évoque dans ce livre grand
reporter confession au coeur des
conflits un monde qui va peut-être
disparaître
[Musique]
je
nous
[Musique]
bonjour et malras avis
bonjour vincent merci recevoir et bien
c'est un plaisir de vous recevoir et
c'est un plaisir d'avoir livre ce livre
et de le recommander il s'appelle donc
grand reporter confession au coeur des
conflits il est édité chez bold alors
vous commencez dès la première de
couverture par une photo avec un
journaliste le
derrière
un tas de cailloux avec un gilet pare
balles c'est une photo est ce que c'est
pas plutôt un cliché
alors écoutez c'est bien c'est un cliché
vous avez raison mais c'est un cliché en
fait il repose sur une réalité
d'ailleurs ce fut une photo qui a été
prise par un grand photographe qui est
lui-même un photographe de guerre qui
alfred il ya comme ça des gars qui a
remporté plusieurs prix internationaux
et c'est une photo en fait on l'a choisi
parce que c'est une photo en fait de la
guerre en syrie et comme on le voit
évidemment du journaliste sont abrités
mais ils attendent et très souvent en
fait dans ces zones de guerre là on
imagine le public imagine que le
journaliste a sont en fait sous les
bombes doit se faire tirer dessus il
passe aussi beaucoup de temps à attendre
voilà jusqu'à ce qu' il ya une action
que quelque chose en fait comment si on
a trouvé que cette image elle
symbolisait à ses ça en fait ces
journalistes qui se protège qui
attendent en même temps qu'ils sont en
train en fait des valves et on le voit
bien pâlots doit montrer par le
caméraman d'évaluer ce qui est en train
de se passer ou ce qui va se passer
c'est un métier de chasseur être au bon
endroit au bon moment
égouttez en tout cas c'est un métier on
dit que c'est un milieu dans lequel il
faut avoir de la chance en l'occurrence
et oui il faut être au bon endroit au
bon moment après je ne crois pas que le
reporter en tout cas le grand auteur de
guerre mais vous connaissez aussi de
toute façon ce métier-là vincent je ne
crois pas toutefois un métier de
chasseur c'est un métier de chanceux
c'est surtout un métier en fait qui est
déterminé par la curiosité c'est ce que
raconte le confrère dans le livre mais
aussi par un fort sens en fait de
l'engagement et puis et puis le sens
tout simplement c'est à dire que lorsque
l'on va couvrir une révolution je suis
au printemps arabe notamment où un
conflit ou une guerre comme en
afghanistan
il faut savoir pourquoi on décide d'y
aller c'est pas juste pour l'adrénaline
alors peut-être que quand on commence ce
métier il ya évidemment la quête de
laventure le coup d'adrénaline mais avec
le temps rapidement on comprend en fait
que nous sommes là nous sommes des
passeurs en fait un le reporter rapporte
des témoignages rapportent une histoire
l'histoire de gens de gens qui sont
souvent les victimes des conflits des
gens qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
droit à la parole et le reporter est là
pour faire la transition finalement
entre ces gens là géré le passage de
témoin en syrie en afghanistan en irak
que sais-je et puis et puis et puis le
public français qui va découvrir donc
leur témoignage par exemple dans le
figaro où par exemple sur field médias
ou la télévision
pourquoi vous avez vous lu et vous avez
accepté d'écrire ce livre
vous avez raison j'ai accepté parce qu'à
l'origine je ne voulais pas écrire de
livres sur les reporter de guerre parce
que je les ai été moi même pendant
presque vingt ans et que on a là une
phrase dans ce métier vous la connaissez
ce que l'on dit tout ce qui se passe sur
le terrain doit rester sur le terrain et
lorsque mon éditeur mais il faut parler
de ce métier de ceux de votre métier
parce que les 10 le mans les français
critiquent de plus en plus alors je dis
ça moi depuis l'espagne je vous je
réside aujourd'hui mais les français
critiquent de plus en plus les médias le
journaliste il faut raconter quand même
quel est le travail de ses journalistes
de terrain qui vont prendre des risques
encore une fois par sens
par engagement et donc il a fini par me
convaincre j'en ai parlé à quelques
confrères alors il ya régis le sommier
de paris match il a parlé d' alfred dire
que vous avez garé au magazine a publié
ces photos plus d'une fois jean pierre
canet etc je leur ai posé la question il
motive hills est intéressant c'est
peut-être effectivement le temps
d'apporter en fait un éclairage sur ce
qu'est notre profession et de témoigner
en fait simplement de notre engagement
pour informer également de la marche du
monde
dans ce livre donc c'est pas simplement
vous mais il ya des témoignages donc
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui ont
été à la fois grand reporter est
également correspondant ça ça oui
exactement j'ai choisi en fait ce livre
dresse le portrait de tous ces
journalistes qui vont sur des zones ce
qu on appelle les zones à risque
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas que des zones
de conflit les zones dangereuses sans
qu'elles soient forcément ouverte à des
conflits et oui je me suis intéressé par
exemple à la consoeur clarence rodriguez
qui a été correspondante en 12 ans en
arabie saoudite
vous comprenez j'ai vécu dans le golfe
persique être journaliste en arabie
saoudite ou au qatar ses pelles être
journaliste en france vous êtes sont des
états policiers donc vous êtes fric et
en permanence clarence le raconte très
bien c'est un peu la double peine elle
est à la fois journaliste et en plus
femmes en arabie saoudite un magnifique
témoignage alors justement vous avez
pris l'exemple en première de couverture
donc d'un reporter qui en syrie mais
est-ce que c'est pas pardonnez-moi mais
un mauvais exemple parce que la syrie ça
a été l'un des premiers terrains où il a
été quasiment difficile de travailler de
manière indépendante
alors non je crois que ce n'est pas un
mauvais exemple parce qu'il illustre
aujourd'hui ce que sont devenus en fait
les nouveaux terrains votre question
fatale et je la trouve très très bonne
parce que c'est un débat qu'on a eu en
fait avec avec l'éditeur d'un v10 je
suis très très honnête c'est un débat
qu'on a eue avec l'éditeur est justement
d'un truc c'est très intéressant en fait
de prendre et vous verrez d'ailleurs
dans le dans le dans le livre un jeu
consacré énormément en fait de
témoignages d'aujourd'hui à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui au proche et au
moyen-orient les conflits au
complètement évolué bien évidemment je
raconte mais d'autres confrères le
raconte parmi la quinzaine de
témoignages aujourd'hui lorsqu'on voit
dans un pays comme la syrie
évidemment on a le risque d'être
embarqués se faire tuer par une armée
mais aussi le risque d'être pris en
otage voir décapité bien sûr par ces
milices djihadistes par le par les
terroristes donc c'est un exemple qui
est important parce que c'est l'exemple
du moment et on a une pensée pour nos
confrères qui sont morts en syrie
notamment yves 2b notamment gilles
jacquier mais également tous nos
confrères étrangers qui ont été sont
morts parfois justement durant leur
captivité
question que je posais à xavier gorce
lundi est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
dire que la fracture dans les médias
aujourd'hui et dans le journalisme est
entre ceux qui conçoivent leur métier
comme étant de dire le vrai et ce qui le
conçoivent comme étant de dire le bien
et vous des jeux partage ça je trouve
que depuis quelques années et ce n'est
pas propre à la france je pense que
c'est propre à beaucoup en fait de pays
européens mais même aux états unis il ya
une espèce de doxa il ya des choses que
l'on peut dire d'autre que l'on ne peut
pas dire alors moi je vois bien la
différence parce qu'aujourd'hui la
rédaction fils médias qui est un site
d'informations disant parlier qui est au
fond c'est évidemment qui que j'ai créée
j'ai contribué à créer avec payer porter
qui est un qui est un site de grand
reportage d'actualité internationale on
l'a mis en espagne on a la parole très
libre on peut parler de tout sans tabou
sans être mis dans un camp du bien du
mal aujourd'hui pour moi c'est de moins
en moins le cas en france évidemment on
voit bien que la notamment la culture
rock a fait des dégâts et des choses
qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'il ya une
pensée en fait aujourd'hui que les eaux
venues en fait de suivre ici on va
contre on n'est ni systématiquement en
fait dans le camp dans le camp des
méchants le journalisme pour moi ce
n'est pas ça le journalisme de les
prononcer un mot qu'intéressant vincent
c'est le mot vérité c'est de se
rapprocher le plus possible de la vérité
en allant voir en ce qui concerne les
reporter sur le terrain ce qui se passe
pour rapporter ce que l'on a vu ce que
l'on a entendu bref pour être au plus
proche des c'est ça le boulot du dû
reporter
la justice britannique est amené à
étudier aujourd'hui le cas de julian
assange le fondateur de wikileaks qui
avait publié des milliers de
correspondances diplomatiques
américaines et qui a dû être par la
suite reclus des années à l'ambassade
d'équateur pour vous c'est un lanceur d'
alerte ou c'est un irresponsable
alors se craignaient que vous me posiez
la question de l annonceur dallaire tout
un journaliste en fait je pense qu'il
est pas irresponsable vous savez soyons
soyons honnête avec les gens qui nous
écoutent dans ce moment nous sommes
nombreux les journalistes à avoir
utilisé finalement les révélations de
julian assange être allé regarder ces
fameux l'x mois chez être beaucoup
travaillé sur l'afghanistan notamment il
est d'ailleurs poursuivi notamment pour
ça parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
révélations d'un faux confidentiel de
câbles diplomatiques et militaires qui
concernait en fait les guerres d'irak et
d'afghanistan
je serai bien hypocrite aujourd'hui de
ne pas dire qu'il faut le défendre
sachant que comme d'autres je suis allé
regarder ce qu'il avait fait ce qu'il
avait produit et que parfois ça nous a
servi d'ailleurs dans nos enquêtes
la réalité elle est là
quel est votre point de vue sur le
phénomène des défaites news aujourd'hui
est ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
pensaient que ça explose ou bien est ce
que on joue à se faire peur
non je pense qu'il ya une caisse de
résonance que sont les réseaux sociaux
évidemment qui met en avant fait les de
plus en plus les faits qui use il y a
annoncé tous les deux puisque on fait
comme on dire nous avons nous dirigeons
des rédactions en ligne de plus en plus
de sites internet d'information qui
apparaissent alors moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya pas plus de fake
aujourd'hui une caisse de résonance
souvent qu'ils viennent de particuliers
et non pas en fait de médias mais bien
sûr il ya aussi des médias des pseudos
médias qui ne sont pas pour moi en fait
fiable du tout mais je pense qu'en
général on les voit très vite mais
c'était vrai il ya 50 ans aussi sauf que
ces médias avaient bénéficié pas en fait
de la caisse de résonance que peuvent
être facebook ou twitter
aujourd'hui question d'un internaute
ouest france a décidé de ne pas faire
ont commenté les sondages à quand le
tour du figaro alors non le figaro
continuera publier votre sondage quel
est votre point de vue justement sur ce
sur ce genre de décision
écoutez j'ai appris ça j'imagine comme
votre auditeurs il ya 24 heures ou 48
heures écoutez je me suis posé la
question du coup ça m'a interpellé parce
que je considère que le rôle du
journaliste c'est aussi d'être
interpellé je respecte cette décision
mais je pense que le sondage n'est en
fait le sondage c'est une indication je
dirais dans un temps donné à un moment
donné donc je pense qu un peu comme nous
tu penses que phil médias qui n'en
publient pas beaucoup mais continuera
quand même assiette et à s'y intéresser
parce que si l'on fait du reportage on a
aussi besoin de faire de l'analyse je
dirais que l'un ne va pas sans l'autre
on peut pas dissocier le journaliste de
terrain du journaliste qui va analyser
si vous voulez au sein de la rédaction
l'analyse tout simplement et donc le
sondage ça fait partie aussi quand même
de l'information après il faut savoir
que c'est une information une indication
à un instant donné et alors vous êtes un
spécialiste de l'actualité
internationale
et vous publiez énormément de grands
reportages sur fil médias ce qui fait
l'intérêt en plus d'analyser également
mais ce qui fait l'intérêt de votre de
votre site on parlait à l'instant de la
hongrie est ce qu'il est difficile de
votre point de vue pour un journaliste
de travailler dans une démocratie
libérale genre justement la hongrie la
pologne la slovénie la république
tchèque
écoutez
difficile non qui moi j'ai eu l'occasion
en l'occurrence en plus d'aller dans
certains pays en fait que vous venez de
citer
difficiles n'ont parfois compliqué avec
les autorités en fait je pense que il
est parfois difficile d'avoir un accès
si vous voulez un accès au très ouverts
faites aux autorités au monde politique
il ya pour le coup ne pas défectueux il
ya beaucoup en fait deux comment dire
parfois de langue de bois ou de en tout
cas de comportements d'encadrement qui
ne correspondent pas à la façon dont on
fait de la formation dans un pays comme
la france ou l'espagne où on est on est
tout à fait libre donc je dirais que les
journalistes n'ont pas la même marge de
manoeuvre dans ces pays là il gagne plus
difficile si vous voulez l'aider tout à
l'heure d'aller faire de l'information
en syrie ou en libye quand ambri
évidemment alors effectivement on va
faire la différence entre la syrie et la
hongrie bien entendu et est ce que
justement
les terrains de deux guerres les
terrains où il était jusqu'à présent
difficile mais pas complètement
impossible de travailler je prends
l'exemple la différence entre la libye
de 2011 où c'était compliqué dangereux
mais possible avec la différence avec la
sienne ou travaillés étaient soit se
faire justement embarqué par les
autorités gouvernementales soit être à
la messe la merci d'un certain nombre de
groupes
deux seigneurs de guerre ou de groupes
terroristes
est ce que justement les terrains entre
guillemets ce qu on dit dans le jargon
les terrains pour y ne se sent pas
multiplier ou bien les terrains interdit
je pense notamment à la corée du nord
alors la corée du nord c'est une
constante si je puis dire depuis
plusieurs décennies mais par contre là
où vous avez raison vincent c'est que
les terrains pour y se sont multipliés
alors moi je pense qu'ils se sont
multipliées s'il voulait y aller il ya
deux dates pour moi il ya d'abord
évidemment le 11 septembre en fait de
byd à l'intervention en fait en
afghanistan
et puis les risques si vous voulez pour
les journalistes qui vont là bas de se
retrouver pris en otage un milices
terroristes
qui ont considéré que les journalistes
en fait avait une valeur marchande et
qui vont les couper en morceaux parfois
les exécuter face caméra pour faire leur
communication donc ça évidemment le
terme de terrain pourri pour moi
vraiment commencé comment dire commence
là et puis il ya comment dire dans la
graduation des terrains pour y arriver à
faire daniel deuxième période c'est oui
vous avez raison c'est ça exactement et
puis ensuite il ya les prêtent le début
des printemps arabes vous avez parlé en
fait de ces terrains comme la libye
comme la syrie et 7 x ça devient
extrêmement dangereux d'aller là bas
parce qu'en plus d'al-qaïda vous avez
d'autres milices qui se sont créés il ya
bien sûr des shs et là ils font je
dirais lors comment dire leur comme sur
les prises d'otages les exécutions les
assassinats par abonnement pas les
exécutions et les assassinats les
meurtres de journalistes qui chim donc
oui bien sûr je partage ça y est de plus
en plus de théâtre qui sont extrêmement
compliquées pourri pour reprendre votre
expression ce dont je parle dans le
livre d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
l'opinion qui est plébiscitée dans les
usages chez chez les consommateurs
d'information que nous sommes ou bien
que sont les internautes est ce que
il y a encore une curiosité du public
pour ce que rapportent les grand
reporter ça nous intéresse nous nous
journalistes mais est-ce que ça
intéresse encore les gens même si
claudius nous dit et qu'il a beaucoup de
respect pour ces professionnels qui
risquent leur vie
écoutez je ne sais pas quoi vous
répondre malheureusement c'est une
question que je me pose quotidiennement
alors moi j'y crois je peux répondre ça
c'est à dire que je suis grand reporter
j'ai couvert des conflits pendant des
années et j'ai la chance d'avoir des
grands porteurs français très
prestigieux étrangers aussi qui ont
suivi ma décision de créer un site
d'information internationale avec schild
mais on se rend compte que c'est très
difficile que les gens ne s'adonnent pas
comme ça chez elle nous regarde et par
contre on voit qu'on a un vrai succès
aujourd'hui d'audience sur le grand
reportage c'est très clair je formulerai
peut-être la question différemment c'est
est ce que les gens sont prêts à payer
pour avoir de l'information qui vient de
syrie d'irak d'afghanistan
j'avoue que de plus en plus je me pose
la question je crois que les gens ont
pris le pli finalement d'une information
qui doit être gratuite or l'information
vous savez vous faites partie d'une très
grande rédaction ça coûte extrêmement
cher envoyer des journalistes en
afghanistan ou en irak les gens n'ont
pas forcément en fait conscience de cela
ils n'ont pas conscience du fait non
plus parfois que ces risques auxquels
nous sommes exposés
implique que nous achetions des
assurances des gilets pare-balles enfin
bien évidemment tout ça coûte très cher
donc c'est une vraie une vraie question
que vous allez à nouveau une vraie
réflexion
que j'ai moins quotidiennement je pense
comme nombre de mes confrères en fait
aujourd'hui en tout cas une chose est
sûre il faut que le grand portage
continue à vivre ce soit au figaro à
paris match sheffield médias c'est
vraiment important il peut pas y avoir
d'information objective sans information
un moment donné de terrain merci
beaucoup
chavez emmanuel razavi on retiendra
justement cette sphère cette formule si
vous rêvez de découvrir le métier de
grand reporter ce livre est pour vous il
est très juste il raconte très bien le
quotidien de ces femmes et ces hommes
qui ne sont pas exceptionnelles mais qui
sont confrontés selon la formule des
manuels razali à des situations
exceptionnelles grand reporter au coeur
des conflits c'est aux éditions bold et
c'est extrêmement intéressant même quand
on connaît ce métier et on vous
recommande bien sûr on le met dans le
chat film médias c'est passionnant plein
de repos stage et bien sûr à suivre les
les analysent également qui sont
développés nous on se retrouve demain
même heure même endroit avec d'ici là
d'autres infos d'autres vidéos mais
toujours sur le figaro
[Musique]